i'm pretty excited that we get to have
some wine
guys excellent hey guys it's katie and
for the next 14 days i'm gonna be trying
out the mediterranean diet i've actually
been wanting to do this for a very long
time because it actually seems more like
a lifestyle change than a super
restrictive way of eating and it
apparently has many health benefits such
as increasing life expectancy reducing
major chronic diseases and improving
your quality of life and well-being
there's been celebrities that have also
attested to its health benefits like
selena gomez penelope cruz and john
goodman i kind of want to undo some bad
habits that i've created over the last
two years in quarantine out of
quarantine and just commit to my health
and happiness so to get started i spoke
with a dietitian and basically the
mediterranean diet is an eating plan
based on the traditional cuisines of
greece italy and other countries
surrounding the mediterranean sea it's
mainly plant-based and emphasizes the
intake of whole grains fruits and
vegetables healthy fats such as olive
oil as well as nuts and legumes over the
intake of animal protein which is
usually served in smaller portions
typically fish or seafood is the
preferred meat and it's also about your
lifestyle so sharing meals with others
not watching the tv or being on the
computer when you're eating being
present and connected and also partaking
in daily activities that you like like
walking your dog or riding a bicycle the
things to avoid on this diet are
processed foods refined grains and foods
with added sugars which is gonna be hard
for me while alcohol is usually for just
special occasions you can have a glass
of red wine a night if you like which i
would like i think this is doable i'm
gonna try my best so let's try it so day
one of this diet started a little bit
rough okay so i was supposed to go
shopping and meal prep last night but i
ended up sitting in about 10 hours of
traffic so i just really didn't feel
like doing it so today i'm gonna see
what i have in my pantry and then go to
the store do shopping and get myself set
up for the rest of the week so that
morning for breakfast i basically had to
just look around my kitchen see what i
had and i scrounged up some loosely that
i cooked in water i added an old banana
that was about to go bad some chopped
walnuts cinnamon and just kind of like
threw something together that's pretty
good
not the best thing i've ever had for
breakfast but sweetness of the banana
the crunch of the walnut i can see how
this would be a very filling meal so
after i had breakfast i headed out to go
shopping this is my receipt very long to
be ribbon dancer
i got tons of fruits and vegetables i
don't love vegetables so it was weird to
get this many like asparagus i'm excited
to push myself out of my comfort zone
and cook so i'm gonna put all of this
stuff away and then i'm gonna start
making dinner so i made some whole wheat
pasta with this pesto that used baby
arugula spinach lemon
almonds i never had anything like it it
was really tasty i put that all together
and to make it a little bit heartier i
threw in some white beans there was no
meat but that was okay i'm pretty
excited that we get to have some wine i
am excited to eat those i am too this
doesn't feel like a diet if this was a
pasta only diet
it'd be easy
that's really good i think we'll also go
on a walk tonight because part of the
mediterranean lifestyle and diet is like
eating with other people sharing a meal
walking around and then maybe doing some
exercise you enjoy great we're walking
in the dark do you feel healthy oh we're
in the shower this is the creepiest
video that's ever been made i love it
it's so creepy don't poop rizzo
let's get her poo in on vid no good
morning it is day two of the
mediterranean diet and last night's
dinner was really good and so it doesn't
really feel like i'm dieting at all
because carbs are not off limits on this
diet i missed dessert last night but i
think you know i'm a grown-up the glass
of wine was kind of dessert on its own
and overall i'm feeling good and i'm
ready to make some breakfast i made one
of my favorite things avocado toast so i
took some whole wheat bread and then i
mashed up an avocado with like lime
juice garlic powder and then i topped
that with some cherry tomatoes salt
capers and then i just sprinkled it with
some chives it was so good it was quick
to make i don't always normally eat
breakfast but i do feel like it's
important when you're starting a diet to
try to make sure you're incorporating
that in and i just had leftovers of that
pasta for lunch and for dinner i made a
really easy soup basically what i did is
i heated up some olive oil added onion
carrots and celery cooked that down to
the nice and soft about five minutes
then i added some salt some garlic
rosemary added in some chicken stock and
some tomatoes come up to a boil and then
i simmered that for 30 minutes at the
end just added in some white beans and
kale popped it off with some bread at
the very end aha
this is really good i like it yeah i
love the freshness of the kale in it and
then it just tastes nice and hearty and
homey yeah and we haven't had meat now
for two days and i haven't missed it so
no not at all been good so day three i
actually had to film off-site and i just
threw together a really quick breakfast
with the muesli and i added some chopped
dried fruit i thought i was gonna like
it but i absolutely did not this was
probably one of the least favorite
things that i ate but by the time i got
home for my shoot and it was dinner i
was in a much much better mood and my
husband and i actually cooked together
that day and we made this sheet pan
chicken with all these peppers and
vegetables and potatoes and you can eat
potatoes on this diet which i'm a big
fan of because i love potatoes day three
dinner and this looks delicious wait
don't be crazy i am grace what's his
name
this looks amazing
what are you doing it's my face day
three dinner and i think this was really
good i think it looks great i'm excited
to have some chicken
we have not had meat for two and a half
days that's good the sweetness of the
pepper and the tomato is almost like
jammy
that's good day four is like hard for me
to talk about because my cat was sick
started to get sick and we took him to
the vet and so i didn't have time for
breakfast and you know we got home that
day and ended up passing away
which is was really hard and so instead
of making you know some poor choices
which i think i go to food for comfort
but the one thing i will say is because
i'd been cooking all week i had all
these leftovers being able to kind of
sustain yourself through such an
emotionally draining time i'm so glad
that i had like cooked earlier in the
week and also had healthy things in the
house but believe me i didn't you know
stay quite on track like we ordered out
one night because i just could not bring
myself to cook at all and i ordered pho
you know i definitely had a cookie by
day eight i was getting back on track
because i wanted to commit to taking
care of myself but this wasn't really
about work or anything like that like
eating healthy was about
me and so i got back on track made
myself breakfast and i had avocado toast
and i put an egg on it and it was
delicious that night i made one of my
favorite dishes which is whitefish
piccata i just want to show you that i
don't have enough counter space so
when i'm working here sometimes i put it
on a stool
it's like a pile of fish bones dinner on
day eight is a white fish bakata i
definitely struggled tonight with uh
flipping the fish and like lots of bits
got stuck on the bottom i think it looks
great might have been too hot maybe it
was because i used whole wheat flour
instead of ap flour
that's very tasty it's different with
the whole wheat flour for sure but but i
like it though it still works really
well with the whole wheat flour yeah day
nine i was really getting into the diet
it was feeling like less of a chore and
i had made a beautiful lunch of tomatoes
with this kind of salsa that went over
the top it was very yummy and chris and
i actually sat down and had lunch
together that is something we haven't
really been able to find the time to do
while we've been working from home maybe
he's in a meeting when i'm ready to eat
or i'm in a meeting when he's ready to
eat but this day we found time we sat
down we had lunch together and it was
really really nice
[Music]
oh goodness
nice acidity nice kick i love it i love
it for dinner though dinner was my
favorite i had gnocchi i am not sure if
it's totally okay to eat on this diet
but i don't care i had it it was
delicious i made it with peas and
asparagus and it was so filling so i
have never felt hungry while doing this
diet okay are you ready yeah okay you
know what i like about that yeah
everything everything it was one of my
favorite recipes i found it online and
if you have to make alterations for them
to work it's pretty easy to do just take
out the butter add some oil not a big
deal i'm having lunch at work and i
definitely am breaking some rules day 10
was a real challenge for me because i
actually had to go in to film at work we
were filming a loss in translation i
didn't eat breakfast that morning and
when you're on set you order lunch they
choose to go out to somewhere and i
hadn't really ordered out while trying
to strictly follow this diet this diet's
a little bit hard to order out i should
have gotten some brown rice today i got
regular rice but i didn't have a lot of
time to make my lunch order i just went
for it and i got spicy tuna at least i'm
having fish that's good an avocado
that's good everything has processed or
has something additive to it
oh wait oh my gosh there's pistachios i
can have pistachios what was really nice
that day is i came home and chris was
making me dinner what are we having
we're gonna have some sort of uh spicy
crusted salmon and beans dinner tonight
looking good chris
[Music]
that's excellent
i'm not a huge fish fan i'm not a big
salmon fan so i say so fishy but this
doesn't taste super fishy it's like
every meal i have i'm like oh this may
be one of my favorite meals it's pretty
good i guess it's another dinner just
you and me
we always watch tv when we eat dinner
almost always but this is the tenth day
where we had just sat down and talked to
more and honestly i think it's been
really good for our relationship like if
you can sit down with your family when
you have time and eat together i highly
recommend it day 11 i am really starting
to crave some desserts so i find a
recipe online a tasty recipe actually
that for yogurt bark so you just combine
some yogurt some berries you blend it
all up freeze it for a few hours and
you've got yogurt for dinner this night
i really wanted to mix it up i'm gonna
make pizza i found a recipe for a whole
wheat crust online so do that tonight
because you can eat pizza on the
mediterranean diet and i feel like if
you can you should so i find a recipe
online and i make this whole wheat dough
it takes a while because it has to prove
and then move again but then chris
joined me and we did all the toppings
together we just used some stuff i had
left over from the week like tomatoes
cherry tomatoes we added some fennel
because we love fennel and we did a
little bit of parm usually i would do
like a ton of cheese but you eat less
cheese on this diet so i'm trying to
stay true to that hey
california pizza
can't even wait to sit down i'm gonna
try this pizza i'm so hungry
how is it it's very good but it's
definitely tomato pie
don't have like the cheesiness that like
a big big cheesy pie would have but i
don't mind it and the wheat crust is
good definitely not as good as your
regular old pizza crust but it's still
yummy survey says
one crisp thumb up chris i made dessert
tonight
whoa
oh my head's freezing off my hand's
freezing up oh my god you're gonna burn
your fingers should we try it what is
that it's yogurt and berries
oh i just said berries like you say
berries berries some berries a little
tart i like that though
yeah it is
for breakfast this morning i'm having
some toast with an egg and some berries
this is my second egg of the week i
don't think that's too many eggs it's i
usually would have like two or one a day
so i've really cut back from my normal
like eggs for breakfast and i didn't
have any avocado so couldn't use any
avocado this is what we got cheers
[Music]
it's oozing yes i like your sweater
your sweater's very cute day 12 of the
mediterranean diet i'm almost at the end
of it i thought i'd be like oh i can't
wait for this to be over but actually it
doesn't feel
crazy different i feel healthy i feel
happy i'm going on a walk with my dog so
just a couple more days ago
definitely can do it i also had pizza
leftovers for lunch it was a super easy
day but i knew the real challenge was
coming the next day day 13 was my mom's
birthday and we threw a big party for
her with all her family the party i'm
having a cocktail just a little one
there was mini bundt cakes there was a
beautiful charcuterie board my sister
made tons of mexican food that we
ordered from my mom's favorite mexican
restaurant cocktails and i partook in
them all but it was a special occasion
yes i went away from the diet but again
i didn't feel guilty about it because on
special occasions you can indulge in
this morning it is day 14 of the
mediterranean diet and i've got to say i
woke up i slept in and i still feel so
tired like my body feels very lethargic
and i honestly think it's because i ate
all that food yesterday like really rich
food and i just kind of kind of amazed
how quickly my body has i think started
to change with that diet i'm gonna go
down and have breakfast with my family
and there's gonna be lots of temptations
but it's the last day of the diet and
i'm just gonna try to like keep on track
and uh hopefully i'm gonna feel better
by this evening and that night i flew
home and when i got back chris was
cooking for me again and he made a
beautiful dinner that was zoodles and
shrimp and i hate zucchini like i hate
it but i loved this dinner so maybe i
don't hate zucchini maybe i love it we
did however on the last night watch the
season finale of one of our favorite
shows while we ate this diet for me was
never about losing weight but i did lose
four pounds and in two weeks that's a
pretty healthy amount of weight to be
losing and to be indulging in some like
you know sweets and stuff during it i
feel good about that i overall just like
feel like my mental health is better and
i have more energy i think across the
board it was a lot of work to make your
meal plans and go shopping and do all
that prep but at the end of the day it
made my life so much easier planning my
meals for the week that is so helpful as
the week goes by and it helps you make
the right choices if you have the right
food in your house you're gonna make
better choices the diet is super
customizable so there's no quantities
that you have to eat of something
there's no calorie counting i didn't
feel any guilt which i think a lot of
times guilt comes when you're dieting
and i don't like that it sets me up for
failure give it a try if you want to
thank you guys for watching
[Music]
you